you Kipp are urging the government to
make a clean exit from the EU as their
party conference gets underway in
Birmingham today and you put me there
Darrin batten joins us from there now
good morning to you what's the main
message that you're wanting to get
across with your interim manifesto
policies for the people well the main
message is that we want to be a populist
party in the real meaning of the word
which is that we want policies that are
actually popular with the general
population so that they'll vote for us
the first and policy will be the primary
policy of you kit for the last 25 years
which is to have a clean as you say the
clean exit from the European Union we
fear that we're going to be betrayed
over brexit Mrs May has no real
intention of taking us out properly so I
my job and UKIP's job is to restore
itself as an electoral threat because it
was their electoral threat that achieved
the referendum and now we have to put
the pressure on to say that either we
get out of the European Union cleanly or
you kit will be coming after your seats
we will be losing people their seats in
marginal seats on slim majorities that's
our strategy at the moment going forward
and I want to build UK as a force for
the future I want to point it in the
right direction so that it's a real
force in politics and of course if we
had a fair voting system in this country
proportional representation system which
is another policy that's in this
manifesto then of course we would have
had in peas years ago and we would now
be a major player in the House of
Commons we labor under very difficult
situation at the first-past-the-post
system but we had a real effect without
having a let one and he elected over the
years and I want to see us achieving
that again and going forward to the
point where we can actually get MPs
elected to Westminster you're saying
that you you see yourself as being a
major player on the political stage some
would say that you're moving towards
that the far right or you actually
courting the far right how would you
address that criticism all right let me
address it this way for the last 25
years and myself and everybody a new kid
has worked to restore our country's
former status as an independent
democratic nation that's governed by our
politicians elected by us seqable by us
in accordance with our traditional laws
and customs and constitution now if that
makes you far right then I think whoever
thinks that has got a very strange idea
about what constitutes far white
far-right politics having always been a
democratic party bringing Tommy Robinson
into UK well first of all that's
something that isn't going to happen in
the near future the rules would have to
be changed to allow that to happen as
I'm on record of saying I think that
that is something that I personally
would approve of but it's a matter for
the party it's their decision it's not
mine it's I'm not a dictator and I'm
going to gauge the mood of the party on
that as I mingle around today I'll be
very busy over the next two days talking
to many of those thousand people who are
coming and see how they feel about it it
was the Democratic football lads
Alliance that their Facebook page
criticized for racist rants continuously
and you spoke on on their platform a
platform after which arrests were made
yes and that is that I'm glad you give
them raised that because you give me an
opportunity to comment on the absolute
disgraceful coverage of that by Sky News
when you portrayed that as an
anti-muslim rally it what let me let me
be the one pissed about to tell you
because it wasn't an anti-muslim rally
it was a rally on behalf of justice for
women and children victims of sexual
abuse that I went along to talk because
they invited me the DFL I actually
organized the rally and the people who
caused the violence at that at that
meeting we've had a chance to
investigate that and we know the names
of those people and none of them were
members of the VFL a they were not
followers of the earth interlopers who
deliberately came in order to cause
violence if you actually if you did
stand on a stage and talk about sexual
crimes attribute sing them to a religion
the religion of Islam that that's on on
record and I'm not the only person to do
that because people have studied the
ideology of the religion it does it does
actually traditionally for its out his
history makes sex slaves and legitimate
that's possible their profit had sex not
the ideology there is there there is no
about Islam it's in its it's in the
hadith and the Quran it's a tradition
that that's okay to do that and people
take their prophet as the model for all
time and a perfect human being so if he
did something then it's okay for other
people to do it
the problem is with the ideology not
individuals I have never attacked
individuals I always talk about the
ideology and the idea on ideology is the
problem but you're you're attacking the
entire religion of Islam which doesn't
espouse to to actually advocate sex
before marriage many attributes the go
ahead I'm sorry it it does allow it does
allow people to take their followers to
take sex slaves who are not of the same
religion who fires infidels can be taken
as sex slaves it's one of the conditions
of warfare that they have so it's no
good telling me in the world that it
doesn't happen because everybody no it
does happen and as for ideologies I'm
against totalitarian ideologies I hate
communism hate Nazism I don't want to
live in any way shape or form under a
totalitarian ideology and if you look at
every country in the world where Islam
is predominant there are very repressive
regimes or are they regimes that are in
conflict internally and I think that
that is something that we have to be
very wary of when you speak about
particularly that the situation in
Rotherham and that was something that
you spoke about on the platform you
isolate that as a Muslim crime you never
for instance speak about the crimes of
the the Catholic Church in terms of
sexual abuse of children why is it that
you don't speak on a broad spectrum you
isolate it to Islam well I'm
I was on there talking about specific
victims and if you read there's a very
good book on this whole subject called
easy meat by Patrick McLaughlin which
details all of this over about 30 years
20 or 30 years and how it's been swept
under the carpet and is predominantly
people who follow that religion who are
causing this problem on a national scale
which is the industrialized sexual
exploitation for money and for their own
perverted purposes so that happens to be
a fact at the moment I'm happy to
condemn pedophilia and child abuse and
sexual abuse wherever it occurs a little
problem with that as far as I'm
concerned then crime whoever commits it
and I'm happy well well you're asking me
now so I'm condemning it I know if I'm
invited to spec invited to speak at that
event I can only go to an event that I'm
invited to speak at and so I think also
if you although you have those crimes in
other institutions we know they go along
everywhere they have no ideological
justification they have no basis which
people could argue that this is
permissible under the [ __ ] they under
the branch of that ideology that they
choose to follow and I know Nigel Faraj
took great care to make you kip a main
stream party he has said that you should
be advised as to the company you keep on
the platform that you spoke at that
rally he suggests that perhaps you
shouldn't be keeping company with the
DFL a what what do you say to that what
I would say to that is that I wonder one
I just said that because Nigel is
friends with Donald Trump that a lot of
people like and call names Nigel has
gone to speak on platforms in Germany
with alternative for Deutschland which a
lot of people don't like and call names
and he's entitled to do that because
there are democratic parties and I'm
entitled to speak at rallies organized
by people who believe in democracy as
well so I think that maybe he should be
a little bit more careful about somebody
similar things you've called Islamic a
death cult do you think you are the the
right person to be speaking on such a
platform and your object him about Islam
and Muslims
well they can invite other people as
well if they want to there's plenty of
Democratic politicians out there that
they can invite
depends who would accept that invitation
and go and speak forth a lot of people
don't want to address this problem
because they're too frightened to talk
about it I meet people all the time and
this isn't just in relation to this
issue but now people are fearful of
speaking out because they are losing
free speech it has can have consequences
for their jobs and careers I feel that I
have a moral responsibility to say what
I think is true because I'm in a
position to do it I'm a leader of a
party I don't need a job next year I can
retire I can go off and get my pension
there are other people out there who've
got jobs and livelihoods and they are
becoming increasingly frightened and
fearful of even admitting they're
members of a political party or stand
for brexit or have other views which are
perfectly permissible but it's becoming
more difficult in our current climate
for actually to express those views
we've got these forces who can't too
busy can't be bothered to investigate
burglaries but it can come around and
knock on your door because you say
something on Twitter they don't agree
with well just one last point for those
that might say you kit is a racist party
I'd just like you quickly to go down
this road on justified visa elements in
your manifesto you want to repeal hate
speech guidelines you want to repeal the
Equality Act of 2010 you want to shut
down the equalities and Human Rights
Commission and you want to shut down the
government equalities office
that's hardly in keeping with diversity
and a multicultural society is it right
first of all we had perfectly good laws
against incitement to hatred incitement
of violence causing public disorder the
problem with the hate crimes is it's
what anybody's perceived notion of a
crime is and it doesn't even have to be
the supposed victim it can be a third
party who can say that's a hate crime
well that's nonsense this is kind of
totalitarian territory where somebody
can say oh I think that person is guilty
of a crime therefore they're going to be
arrested and investigated and possibly
charged under English law for centuries
you had to be guilty of a specific crime
in law not somebody's opinion of whether
it constituted something or not but that
is a very dangerous path to go down
and those we had perfectly good human
rights in this country
under our own English common law we
didn't need to adopt a human rights
legislation which came from the European
Union and we've seen the habit that that
is causing Jared batten thank you very
much for joining us I just wanted to
make sure that you still stand by your
statement that Islam is a death cult
well study its history for the last
fourteen hundred years and if you take
an impartial look at it you might come
to that view as well Julian okay
Gerald batten thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning on Sunrise